We want you to participate virtually
in the World Economic Forum’s Summer
Davos in China this September.
The theme of the meeting is "Driving Growth
through Sustainability".
At the Annual Meeting of the New Champions
held in Tianjin we want to know about YOUR
solutions for sustainability.
How can we manage resources more efficiently?
How can we increase energy efficiency?
How can we lower carbon emissions?
How can we rebuild basic infrastructure?
These are just a few questions that we want
YOU to help answer.
All innovative ideas are welcome because driving
growth through sustainability is fundamental
for global, national and business competitiveness
in the 21st century.
Ready to pitch? Upload your pitch using a
visually stimulating presentation that is
no longer than 2 minutes to YouTube.com/Davos.
The more visual, the better!
Don’t forget to vote for your favourite
presentation too.
The best entry will be shown to some of the
most powerful and influential people in the
world - including presidents and business
leaders - at our Summer Davos in China.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos to join the conversation.